non mais j'ai envie que qu'elle me dise
qu'elle a pensé de la séquence moi je
maintiens
ce que je dis alors
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ton discours est misogyne
il y a un auteur
au restaurant ça choque pas aux
États-Unis on peut partir au restaurant
[Rires]
aux États-Unis on peut aller au
restaurant comme
ça
veut dire que à Londres non mais à
Londres aux États-Unis moi je suis une
fille qui voyage beaucoup donc à Londres
aux États-Unis
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
où on peut voyager
enfin
t'inquiète dis-lui ce que tu as lui dire
défonceuse si tu veux non mais à Londres
on peut s'habiller comme on veut dans
les restaurants donc je vois pas pour
moi le problème c'est ici c'est à dire
c'est la mentalité française dans le
sens où moi je trouve c'est pas normal
que on s'habille pour nous-même en fait
c'est on a envie d'être belle on
s'habille pour nous-mêmes on s'habille
pas pour forcément pour les hommes et
moi je trouve que c'est
avec l'eau du bain
non moi ce que j'aimerais bien parce que
moi je suis je suis un avocat moi ce qui
m'agace c'est chez Guillaume c'est deux
choses la première qu'elle vend le lot
du bain ou quoi elle fait de mal à
personne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est très bien ce que vous avez dit
vous avez tout résumé et Guillaume
franchement moi je te le redis
aujourd'hui j'ai échangé avec Polska une
des deux jeunes femmes allaient meurtrie
parce que tu as dit honte et oui et oui
c'est la réfléchi
[Applaudissements]
calme-toi
moi je vais chercher
l'information à la source voilà tu as
moins appeler Damien Tarek
à travers elle à toutes les femmes il
est temps de t'excuser ce que tu as dit
scandaleux franchement je suis navré
pour toi c'est un grave faux pas retire
tes paroles
n'importe quoi non déjà
rubiny carré est venu défendre ces deux
jeunes femmes parce qu'elles ont le même
gagne-pain et se gagne pas il s'appelle
only fan only fan c'est un site on y va
c'est un site sur lequel on vend des
photos de soi dénudés pour gagner
beaucoup d'argent en fait ce qui
m'exaspère c'est que les filles comme
vous il y a aussi des garçons qui le
font vous êtes tellement prête et prêt à
tout et n'importe quoi pour qu'on croit
que vous êtes des gens importants que
vous êtes des stars que vous êtes
fortunés que le seul moyen que vous
utilisez pour y arriver c'est la nudité
donc vous vendez des photos etc et cette
nudité dans votre monde fictif de l'IFAN
certes ça intéresse les gens j'ai
regardé à essayer de le faire c'est zéro
non mais non mais ça marche bien sûr non
mais très bien il y a un public pour ça
mais là on est dans la vraie vie on est
dans un restaurant
ce pays est-ce que dans ce pays c'est la
dictature en fait non mais rubis moi
c'est le matin je vais prendre quand je
vais prendre un petit déjeuner à 8h du
matin
quand je vais prendre un petit déjeuner
à 8h du matin je n'ai pas envie d'avoir
quelqu'un à moitié à poil à côté de moi
que ce soit un homme ou une femme pour
elle elles veulent plaire ton seul
argument c'est de crier à la misogynie
au maxi mais c'est toi Ruby qui réduit
moi je suis en France ici si j'ai envie
d'aller n'importe quelle heure dans un
restaurant et j'ai envie d'être jolie je
le fais pour moi maintenant c'est à des
hommes qui savent pas se tenir c'est pas
mon problème c'est à dire que
c'est pas possible non mais
[Rires]
on a perdu la 4G d'accord
c'est de crier au machisme et au sexisme
mais pardon c'est toi qui réduit la
femme un objet sexuel à de la
provocation sexuelle à montrer en
permanence et elle existait à travers ça
et je vais vous dire pourquoi vous le
faites parce que non pas du tout je veux
dire pourquoi vous le faites parce que
vous êtes une génération qui ne fait
aucun effort qui ne veut pas travailler
et votre seul moyen d'exister et de
gagner de l'argent facilement c'est de
se mettre à poil et on est
malheureusement on vit dans un monde où
c'est mieux payé de se poser en string
dans un lit que d'aller bosser et ça je
trouve ça déplorable c'est tout
[Applaudissements]
en France
c'est moi qui te parle c'est Siri
qu'est-ce que tu as quel âge
ments dans l'immobilier
avec l'autre main en tout cas mon
objectif
est-ce que tu poses nues sur des sites
dans l'immobilier et
comme il dit qu'est-ce que tu poses des
photos est-ce que tu fais des photos
je suis chef d'entreprise dans le
marketing digital non tu vends des news
à 15 balles sur sur 1000
[Applaudissements]
quel immeuble quel immeuble quel
immeuble
décevoir moi je te le dis vraiment c'est
vrai tu es en train de me décevoir ton
discours est misogyne
est-ce que tu trouves son discours
misogyne
non mais elle alors Ruby juste au rugby
non sans charrier là est-ce que tu fais
des photos que tu fais des nuits est-ce
que tu fais des nudes
c'est plus possible c'est quoi c'est non
mais non franchement
et c'est là parler c'est l'anglais mais
c'est là parler vraiment ça va plus du
tout on va droit dans le mur vos
discours toi Guillaume franchement tu me
déçois c'est misogyne
on est censé être dans un pays libre moi
maintenant si j'ai envie de me pointer à
7h du matin dans un café ou un
restaurant
ou un restaurant
habillé sexy je peux m'habiller sexy
où je suis en France et voilà moi voilà
mais est-ce que aujourd'hui pour comment
tu gagnes comment tu gagnes ta vie elle
vend des immeubles
faut les acheter d'abord comment tu les
as acheté rubis c'est avec tout ce que
tu fais sur les réseaux tu as gagné
beaucoup d'argent
il faut dire la vérité les gens qui
posent dans des voitures de luxe sur
Instagram dans des hôtels de luxe ne
gagne pas leur argent en achetant des
immeubles et en ayant des chefs
d'entreprise comment s'appelle tes
salariés c'est qui tes salariés ce genre
de discours que justement nous les
femmes on se fait harceler dans la rue
ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que moi je
peux plus me promener en mini-jupe ça
rien à voir non mais
rien à voir justement pas avoir ça veut
dire que moi je peux pas me promener en
mini d'ailleurs ce soir
en fait si c'était un homme c'est ce
serait pareil le problème c'est que
pardon mais vous exaspérez tout le monde
vous prenez pour des gens importants des
grandes dames des grands messieurs de la
société en réalité vous ne faites rien
vous ne créez rien vous n'avez aucun
talent vous ne créez aucune valeur vous
ne travaillez pas voilà et tout ce que
vous faites c'est exactement et pardon
mais quelqu'un qui vous regarde sur les
réseaux sociaux je dors deux heures par
nuit énormément
[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est vrai tu fais quoi
ça veut dire que nous en France on peut
pas être libre c'est à dire que nous les
femmes on peut pas être libre et c'est à
cause de votre [ __ ] de discours en
fait que nous on est femme on se fait
harceler en France
Ruby ne le prenez pas mal je suis une
femme donc je vais vous parler avec
beaucoup de tendresse et d'affection moi
je suis complètement d'accord avec ce
qu'a dit Guillaume jourdon moi je pense
que vous êtes là parce que vous êtes un
monstre mais ne le prenez pas mal non
une créature non mais une créature une
créature
un monstre catholique une créature et
numérique des réseaux sociaux c'est pas
péjoratif moi je pense que vous avez
tiré la chasse de votre eau vous avez
tiré
voilà vous êtes in avatar
tikiwinky vous avez tiré la chasse de
votre
haut du bain et aujourd'hui vous êtes en
mal de base moi pour moi
j'ai pas besoin de venir
moi dans ma chambre
nous les femmes ont une femme
dans le sens où justement vous êtes vous
êtes une femme et donc et pour vous donc
vous vous cautionnez le fait justement
qu'un restaurant recale des jeunes
filles parce que elles sont habillées
trop sexy mais vous mais oui c'est pas
ça le sujet moi je pense que vous êtes
là pour les mauvaises raisons vous êtes
là-bas aujourd'hui votre eau du bain ça
c'est rien c'est le haut du bas on parle
pas mais non mais en fait vous venez
parce que vous vous venez parce que tout
à fait
elles sont nuls
sont des amis
en fait
toute la nuit vous le dis c'est vrai
toute la journée toute la nuit la
journée
non j'ai ok j'ai des infos
et que vous venez aujourd'hui nous
expliquer qu'aujourd'hui les femmes on
est en France on est dans un pays libre
on a envie voilà c'est maintenant on a
envie de se faire belle pour nous c'est
pas notre de notre faute si les hommes
ne savent pas se tenir dans le sens où
maintenant voilà si on a envie d'être
jolie pour nous
d'aller dans des restaurants toi qui a
beaucoup voyagé quand tu as été à
Copenhague aux États-Unis
aux États-Unis c'est normal il y a des
filles elles sont sexy et tout genre à
n'importe quelle heure
tu veux dire quelle heure
45 ouais
9h22 moi je parle un principe
pour moi je pense que pendant libre
franchement on est en France et on est
libre et pour moi avec votre discours
Moyen-Âge
2 minutes
on peut s'habiller comme on veut voilà
on a pour le mot je vais te laisser le
mot de la fin
qu'est-ce que tu as à dire à tous ceux
qui de tout est détracteurs ce que tu
veux entendre ce que à dire ce qu'elle
te dit Daniel Moreau la personne là-bas
moi je pense vous parlez beaucoup des
pays et tout ça je pense qu'il y a des
règles dans ce pays je pense que ces
deux jeunes filles étaient très
contentes et que c'était une partie de
provocation elles sont venues en plus
définition c'est du buzz c'est votre
métier moi ça me fait beaucoup de peine
quand hier la jeune fille de 19 ans dit
que sa maman trouve ça très bien du
moment que ça fait de l'argent c'est
affreux j'ai très peur que plein de
jeunes filles prennent modèle sur vous
parce que justement on croit que vous
êtes riche et tout ça ça fait rêver que
vous ayez des immeubles à Dubaï donc
voilà moi tout ça me fait plaisir
vous me faites très très peur pour la
jeunesse pour je souhaite vraiment
je vais vous montrer que
je suis pour la liberté et autant que
femme si je veux me pointer à 7h du
matin sexy je me pointe à 7h du matin
sexy je vais vous montrer tout de suite
merci
juste je pense que vous allez je pense
que vous allez avoir un appel de Gilles
Verdez
pas
il y a des lieux merci non je suis là je
suis là je suis là
[Applaudissements]
ça y est moi je pars en principe en
France on peut
moi
comme je veux
alors
avec vous tous c'est un discours
misogyne on est en France et la liberté
merci alors bravo et si tu pouvais
prêter ton soutien-gorge à Benjamin
[Applaudissements]
on va on va on va revenir sur ce qui
s'est passé là c'est vraiment
l'actualité du jour merci Ruby
habillez vous s'il vous plaît habillez
vous allez s'il vous plaît